our next speaker Her Last Mile
transportation is a non-electric
scooter everyone please welcome Abigail
so the talk I'm going to give today is
fairly technical we're going to talk
about classification about classifying
text we're going to talk about large
language models and I'm going to try to
get you to use a library called Marvin
for if you are doing certain types of
natural language processing tasks with
llms but really why I'm here today and
why I'm talking to you and this group
about about this is that I've now been
around the federal government for 17
years now and I've been a job seeker and
I've also been on the other end of it so
trying to hire trying to bring people in
try to bring technical people in there's
a lot that's really nonoptimal about the
federal hiring process okay so you know
this um if you've applied to us say jobs
there a lot of issues and again having
experience it from both sides there's a
lot that's broken that's really not a
technical issue right we make laws in
certain ways there's policies there's
regulations there is really dispersed
authorities where in order to change
something you really have to talk to
like every single person doing hiring we
can't fix any of that today okay like
that that is all that is off the table
um there's a very small piece that I
want to talk to you about that I think
really is a data problem and that is
making our job announcements more
legible so there's a bunch of text it
describes things we sort of go through
that um and what I'm going to talk about
is how we can use text analysis and
speciically llms to generate more
accurate job titles that really describe
the duties that the agency wrote In The
USA job
description oh no oh my goodness guys I
this is like embarrassing I I clearly
not I'm not up to date okay
so
okay so I've had this experience you may
have had this experience you go to USA
Jobs you search for something I search
for data scientist and they get a whole
variety of jobs they're not really what
I'm looking for okay and we can argue
about like what is data science and that
can be really theoretical and you say
something and I say something else but
the important part here is it's a
problem when with people looking for
jobs who aren't able to find the actual
kinds of jobs they're looking for okay
so I again I look for data science and I
find jobs that are more data analyst or
the business intelligence analyst um
they're looking for somebody to look at
to work in Tableau all day or their
software developer jobs that I don't
have the skills for or they're
leadership jobs which are really
interesting in some ways but not really
what I'm looking for and so that's sort
of the first barrier the first way that
people interact with this website and
interact with Federal hiring is they
look for a job and if we make it hard
for them then we're really erecting
barriers that don't need to be
there okay so we're going to talk about
text classification and how we can use
large language models and a big piece of
this is helping job Seekers right but
another piece of it is internally
there's all these analytics we want to
do okay so we want to know things like
time to hire we might want to know
things like which types of jobs it's
actually really hard to hire for you put
an announcement and it winds up being
failed so you don't actually hire
somebody and so the more information we
actually have about how to classify
these jobs the better we we're in a
position to actually analyze things
internally okay so this is what I want
to do right I want to go to chat GT I
want to say like just show me like
actual data science job postings um
that's not exactly what we do here we
work with apis but essentially like this
is this is what I want to do is like hey
we have this tool it's really good at
text analysis can I just get it to do it
for
me okay so quick detour we're going to
talk a little about classification
problems okay so this is this is the
really standard way we sort of explain
this is with ham and spam so when you
get an email to your inbox behind the
scenes your your email client is doing
some work and what it's doing is trying
to figure out is this something I should
actually send your inbox or is it
something that's spam and it's doing
that with a lot of different features
but one of those sets of features is
just the text in the email so based on
previous emails that have been sent
based on the kind of kinds of feedback
you give so like every time you report
spam Gmail it Updates this model um but
this is just a really basic um you know
two category classification
model and ideally we want to do some
assessments and I'll talk a little about
that so this is actually like this is a
really this would be a really bad model
so we have 479 plus 470 divided by all
of this so it's about 94% are correctly
getting classified for spam that would
be really bad for some other kinds of
problems that are harder that would
actually be a really good model um so
ideally at the end of any classification
problem we would have something like
this where we would actually be able to
assess how well our model is
doing so that's USA jobs listings you
may be familiar with this it's the jobs
listing you can see there's a lot of
different kind of information we start
with like there's a summary you can see
the agency and the salary and then you
can see this Duty section and in the
next slide we'll look in more depth at
one of one what one of those looks like
and that's the text I'm working with for
the actual
classification so this is about to be
there's an audience participation part
we can look this this is an example
duties text section and we can see
there's a bunch of pipelining you're
constructing things you're automating
things you're eliminating manual
participation um all those kind of stuff
you're maintaining
databases um what is this job guys give
me give me throw out something what
would you call this
job data engineer thank you will I I
know will I did not actually tell him to
say that ahead of time he really just
got it right this is a data engineer job
this is a classic data engineer job okay
it's officially labeled scientist right
and this is bad for a couple reasons
this is bad because I look for data
scientists and I Wast a little of my
time but it's really bad because if
you're an actual data engineer we want
you to be able to look up data engineer
and find this position also this
position is actually
misclassified okay so we'll talk a
little about this there are these four
4digit occupational codes which are
pretty clearly defined by the office of
personnel management and data engineer
jobs are really not in 1560 which is the
data science position they're really
they're 2210 this is or they're 15 160s
there's something else I don't really
care about this as much but this is
something that the federal government
kind of does care about a little bit and
this is another thing that you could use
this model for would be detecting which
positions are misclassified internally
okay we can't overcome text ambiguity
problems if you have basically no
information in your duy section then my
model isn't going to be any better at
classifying it than a person reading it
so there sort of again there's problems
we can fix with hiring there's problems
we can't fix with hiring if this is your
duty section I don't know what it
doesn't really matter my mod was gonna
say it's not gonna be very good right I
have no idea looking at this job what it
actually
is okay so um my kind of minimum viable
project workflow I pulled a bunch of
data scientist job listing so by data
scientists mean it is categorized in
occupational code 1560 which is a fairly
new data scientist occupational code it
doesn't mean the title is data scientist
but it means it's broadly supposed to be
a data science job so I pulled those
from the API there's these these great
two USA jobs apis that you should use if
you're interested in this one of his
current jobs one of this previous jobs
this old jobs this is basically 22 2022
present I dropped a handful of them that
had no Duty list or said go to this
other website to find the duties I okay
I'm not doing that um and then I used a
library called Marvin to get structured
output from GPT so really all I wanted
back was a job title right I didn't want
an explanation I I wanted the job title
and so with Marvin I was able to get
that really easily um and then did some
analysis and
iteration Okay so I'm in an R conference
I'm telling you why you should use a
python Library I recognize this is
slightly problematic but why I think you
should use this is because you don't
actually have to write any python code
okay this is like nine lines code none
of it's really python there's one line
to call it and the real work that's
happening here is actually this dock
string so it's this given duties
generate a specific job title based on
the content not based on any titles
contained in the text and this is a
comment but this library is actually
going to use that and how it creates the
prompt to send to GPT that's really the
work that's happening there and the rest
is a class description doesn't really
matter um but this is the library that
does it know the library and it's pretty
easily it's pretty easy to call python
code from R and again like nine lines
like definitely worth it um it means I
don't have to write prompts that say
things like please only give me the job
title in all caps like I don't do any of
that I know what I'm going to get back
is just a really clean job
title okay so what do we actually get
from this we can get a view of the
variety of different roles that are
getting advertised as 1560s um we can
get a prototype job labeling system for
applicants again that we can sort of
give to somebody like this is this is
how you can search um we can get a way
to highlight jobs that might be
mislabeled challenging to hire for or
misclassified I'll talk a little about
that but for instance if my job labeling
system says like this is a chief data
science officer and you're you're hiring
a gs13 like that could be really hard so
we can flag some things that way um and
again a variable that might be
predictive for research and Analysis
this isn't like this is the answer it's
not like Chad GPT is brilliant it gives
us the best answer but it gives us an
answer I think that answer can be really
useful okay so I'll show you some some
graphs we're going to look at overall
difference in top titles between my
classifier and the official job titles
we'll look at at some job titles that
never appear in the official job
listings but do appear in mine and we'll
do some spot checks so here we go
comparing the top 10 job titles of my
llm so that's on the left the things
that GPT generated versus the official
titles so the big thing you'll see is
that data analyst is number two on the
titles that my model generated and it
doesn't appear at all top 10 and those
are really the jobs that are like you're
working in Excel you know maybe you're
making dashboards and maybe those jobs
actually do involve coding maybe the
duty section is not accurate but if
again if this is what the model is
seeing this is what we can expect our
applicants to be seeing also and you can
see here again also there's that sheep
data officer sheep data scientist those
are jobs that aren't necessarily labeled
that way and they're not necessarily
called that but the scope of duties
there is pretty big like these look like
leadership positions um which first of
all is interesting because that's
appealing to people people maybe want
those jobs and so if we're not
advertising that way we're missing out
but also the possible mismatch between
grade or salary and between the scope of
duties
okay so um these are job titles which
appear in the llm generated titles but
never appear in the official job titles
so some of these are not that useful
some of these are things somebody might
want to search for so like geospatial
analyst if I'm a geospatial person I'd
probably like to be able to look for
that if again data engineer appears
there software engineer if it's really a
software engineer job it's probably
misclassified but it might be
interdisiplinary it might be listed
under both um so yeah some of these are
just genuinely interesting job titles
that can a information and that somebody
might really want to look for okay so
some big title
discrepancies this is titled data
scientist um but my model said it was a
data analyst um and you can see like it
mentions macros it mentions pivot tables
it doesn't really mention programming
okay so that's a mismatch um technical
program manager this looks really
interesting like I think a lot of people
would really be interested in this job
you're providing technical leadership
you're providing reports it's not really
a data science
job okay but what's better than ad hoc
assessment is systematic assessment
right like I can show you like this one
worked out well I liked this but really
what we want to be doing here ideally is
actually getting something like what I
showed you for that confusion Matrix
earlier what we want to be saying is how
well does this actually do relative to
the current titling
system okay so how this would work if if
we govern actually wanted to do this is
ideally we would get somebody with
expert knowledge to look at these Duty
sections and they would label them and
they would say this looks like this kind
of job and then it would be a little
complicated how we could actually
compare because what we probably want to
do is some kind of comparison of
semantic meaning like there's so many
job titles here that like realistically
maybe data engineer is straightforward
but what makes something a data science
specialist job versus a data science
manager job so we'd have to do some work
we have to make some other choices but
ideally that's really where this would
go is we do some real systematic
assessments of what these jobs actually
contain and I'll say briefly because I
do a few more minutes um this isn't
exact like I I'm calling this a
classification problem it's not exactly
a classification problem so typically
for classification problems we have a
list of preset categories so like for
instance ham and spam there can be more
than two um this is more it's more like
a generative task so um and that's not
something we really pre- llms you
wouldn't really has a task exactly like
this where you could have done you could
have done a few things either you would
have had multiclass classification where
I could have written out 10 different
job titles and it would sore into
buckets or I could have done something
more unstructured like I could have
clustered my my jobs by how similar they
were and I'm not really doing either of
those so it's not exactly classification
we could make it into a more standard
classification problem where we could
write 10 different job titles and then
other and we get the LM to do that I
tried it it didn't really work very well
and I think part of what's valuable
about this is seeing the real range of
jobs and so it's being able to say this
is a geospatial job even if there's only
two of them we still want to be able to
do that and we're not really going to
come up with categories ahead of time
and that also makes doing the systematic
assessment challenging um but it's still
doable and I think it's still ultimately
worth
it okay so I tried a lot of other things
too I tried named entity recognition so
names entity recognition is another
classic natural language processing
problem and so what I was interested in
was that were the names of of software
tools and programming languages in each
of these because I think that gives you
a lot of information about a job listing
like if job listing says hadow powerbi
python R sta C++ I wish I were making
this up I am not then this is a jobless
thing that's pretty confused about what
they're looking for okay if it says
python R dock or git like cool okay like
we're we're good here um and if it says
again you know if it says sort of excel
powerbi tableau that's probably a data
analyst job and so they probably do know
what they're looking for it's just it's
not really a data science job so I think
that that's really another way of
looking at jobl listings um and it
worked pretty well so again Marvin
really helped with that I was able to
write a prompt which asked specifically
for tools and software and it gave me a
really nice dictionary so it it gave me
just a really nice format any way that I
struggled more to get by myself um so
that works well grouping by category so
saying tell me if this is a management
job a data analyst job again trying to
do a more standard classification
problem with preset categories it didn't
work as well I think maybe there's some
promise there I couldn't really get it
to work and then comparing actual titles
and generated titles so like tell me is
the title you generated you know the LM
made how different is that from the
actual official job listing and that
just really didn't work it just I think
maybe it needed more context about what
I meant by different I wasn't able to
get it okay so what's next um My Hope is
I know a lot of folks here work for the
federal government like you're
interested in hiring um or if you're a
job Seeker who is interested in do some
of this analytically um my stuff is on
GitHub so if you go to my GitHub profile
then like the first thing is you can see
both the slides and the code that
generated all of this so if you want to
use this in some capacity like I'd love
to talk to you like this is very doable
it's very easy to get started like we
really can go very quickly from your
data to some answers um just like
immediately um also if you have a text
class a problem I think you should or
for that matter another type of NLP
problem um I think you should think
about large language models generally as
a way of going again really quickly from
your problem to some data to some
answers and then you can again assess
like it might work it might not but it's
so fast to get started and llms are this
sort of like pre-trained in everything
models where there's so much data
they've been trained on that they might
be good at your problem so llms
generally and also Marvin specifically
um so that you don't have to fight with
the llm to be like give me a dictionary
please that is outputed in this way
please just give me this right with
Marvin you're not fighting with the LM
to do
that okay and yeah that's all um come up
with me afterwards for questions or if
you want to use my code thank
you